the skill itself is being able to detach  during the event the hard part is to  notice you gotta look for those signs  you gotta look for that moment when you  start feeling emotional or you know that  it's gonna be something emotional you've  got a step back from those and get get  yourself in the habit of asking yourself  what do I look like right now what do I  sound like right now listen to the words  that are coming out of your mouth and  see if you're being a reasonable human  or not look for the emotional quicksand  and don't step in it the emotion of the  anger the frustration when you start  feeling the sweat beating up when you  start feeling hot that should be a big  red flag there it is that's the  quicksand of emotion you don't want to  step into it want to pull yourself back  you